autre rassemblement aujourd'hui devant
la cour d'appel de paris
d'associations de défense de
l'environnement et de plusieurs
syndicats objectif protester contre le
nouvel épisode judiciaire dans la sphère
de l'incendié de l'usiné lubrizol à
rouen la justice doit juger la requête
en annulation porté par l'entreprise une
action désespérée pour échapper à un
procès d'après les manifestants
le point sur place avec quatre chapitres
la requête en nullité déposée en août
par les avocats de lubrizol a été
examiné ce matin l'entreprise américaine
a été mise en examen à la suite du
terrible incendie du 26 septembre 2019
au cours duquel 9500 tonnes de produits
chimiques avaient brûlé l'art
aujourd'hui l'entreprise est accusée de
déversement de substances nuisibles
également de manquements ayant porté une
atteinte grave à l'environnement alors
pourquoi les avocats de lubrizol ont-ils
fait cette requête est bien parce qu'il
dénonce des incohérences dans la
procédure d'inspection de la dréal la
direction régionale de l'environnement
même reproche au sujet de l' enquête de
flagrance et de l' enquête préliminaire
il critique également un manque de
loyauté et à une partialité au niveau de
l'inspection
alors cette décision sera rendue en juin
et je vous propose d'écouter les
arguments de bénédicte gros l'avocate de
lubrizol j'entends les inquiétudes des
parties civiles mais je m'insurge
totalement car sur ces propos car il est
essentiel que la défense puisse
s'exprimer que la puise la défense fut
exprimée et déposé des requêtes en
nullité
si elles l'estiment utile c'est un droit
qui est conféré par la loi qui est à
valeur constitutionnelle et qui
appartient d'ailleurs à toutes les
parties à l'instruction judiciaire les
avocats des parties civiles ont réagi au
sortir de l'audience on les écoute il y
à du ressentiment bien évidemment du
côté des parties civiles du côté des
victimes et en même temps il ya beaucoup
de sérénité toute sérénité parce qu'il
ya aucun des arguments soulevés par du
brise hall qui nous paraît
pour voir prospérer donc on attend
sereinement la décision est ensuite que
dossier repartent à l'instruction pour
qu'on puisse avoir enfin un procès dans
cette affaire on a l'impression que
c'était du briseur on ne mettrait
presque que l' incendie a bien eu lieu
chez elle dans ces bâtiments cas t5 et
donc effectivement c'est un sentiment
d'étonnement et d'écoeurement pour pas
dire des clairement dans la mesure où
effectivement les parties civiles aurait
préféré que la sté libre isole assume
ses responsabilités évidemment du côté
des associations des victimes de cet
incendie est bien cette requête en
nullité ne passe pas alors ils sont
venus de rouen ce matin protesté devant
la cour d'appel vers 11 heures et se
dirigeront dans l'après-midi vers
l'assemblée